here we go here we go here we go what is
all you girls playing I think he's going
for 93 again yeah he recently changed
that so let me let me let me think about
this a little bit what is he doing
if I go there are all kinds of endgame
lines there I just wonder what's though
let's do it again I just want to I want
to see that again
I had this recently in a in a Monday
night livestream against him and there
my opening result it wasn't good at all
I wonder if I should go is six this is
also possible a team and something that
I have played before let's try it six I
mean it's also not a terrible move I
mean I think 93 is stronger objectively
speaking so what is he doing just
trading everything down yes of course
okay and that should that should bury
bit just equal right okay let's remember
it's switch off the analysis box we only
only needed after the game okay I'm
going to go to f7 here
he might have Bishop a4 to b3 but I
don't think this is all that threatening
yeah just taking everything on d5 is not
the way to play for an advantage but we
know how he how he plays and he wants to
play those is a very him dry positions
and then on the one hand grind them out
and on the on the other hand win the one
time and he's very very good with this
okay so what's going on here he wants to
go Knight b3 to b5 probably I could play
and I can play a rope here to the 8th
and go 97 this is probably not such a
bad idea anyway the knight coming to f5
this is something that's not a bad
square and if he removes the bishop you
would probably go to e2 right you would
probably go to E - yeah no okay but this
looks pretty pretty harmless right do I
trade one look I don't know if I should
but it's probably not a bad choice
so we trade everything down if I go I
can I can go Knight f5 here as well I
mean just put it on f5 and I wonder if I
go rook c7 it takes takes 935 and like a
b5 you see getting to this pawn I mean I
don't see it I don't see how so
I don't mind the trade I have two better
bishop in this position b5 the thing is
you always have to be on the lookout
because he really is good at the endgame
so even the most dry boring-looking
positions he finds ideas it's not like I
mean he does those time plays
that's why is so well liked but he is
very good in the end game and he has
often just simply outplayed me in those
in those very simple-looking position so
I'm definitely energy I tried to be it
should be six good hmm I mean what's the
deal if he most of the night I take the
pawn it might be three a five is better
than me I mean I just have two better
ending here or not I mean what what am I
missing here if he lets me take it I go
deep walking in 65 and probably would
pick up that pawn at least I don't see
how he prevents it okay five or is this
wrong somehow maybe I'm not
understanding this position correctly I
really have some some healthy respect
for his end game play but I don't really
see it I mean I think I'm just better
here so 95 otherwise he drops the floor
for nothing like c5 I'm taking it
d4 bishop moves King e6 King D five I
mean I should win this pawn in the long
run I mean is he going for before or
something
I'm still winning the pawn and now
pointed before winning this one I don't
like to put this on before but if I win
c5 I'm willing to do things so here is
there some neat no let's let's take this
first and now see what how I do it him
he also put this on a dark square which
is not bad
Knight to c5 would be good if I can get
this and get this going let's check this
first a little bit more Knight a5 is
going to go King C - okay I can then
then trade D against B pawn but I lose I
lose the b-pawn probably as long as it
keeps the bishop on d2 it's that some
kind of suits long that I can get him
into no but I can do this actually and I
can I can protect the pawn going to d5
was pretty useless wait wait wait wait
wait if I do this he might take on
before take on d4 and get to those pawns
this is something that I have to have to
be aware of
hmm I'm not sure I have the the right
key to this position yet probably I have
not and I want to be cautious here I
would have to probably huh and have to
go back I hope that's not a three fold
it would be a little bit bit awful okay
that's not a three fold yeah but okay
from here he's not attacking before
anymore so night if I should win
actually this should win time morning
check check
quite resolve and down he goes yeah and
recent games must go it's not that bad
it really isn't
I'm getting I'm getting somewhere okay
they get Easter yeah I mean sometimes
this was just a bit too simple and what
he did all right this is what simplistic
which probably probably applies I guess
it's not much at home in iqp positions I
don't know it's a bit a little bit
strange to take on d5 him because then
it's pretty clear that white has nothing
I mean Bishop g5 is what he probably
should do this is what I played actually
myself in the tournament game like when
was that a week ago right
yes a week ago I played Bishop g5 in my
tournament game and then Bishop d7
Bishop h6 I think this is the way to go
for white with chances for a slight
advantage it's nothing special in black
is quite okay in this variation here
it's not brilliant but it's okay but I
think here the thing is that here with
with this
I think I'm rather black here I mean
it's probably equal but if you look at
the center I'm the one who's putting
some pressure on the pawn it is
defending it and there is really no no
reason any reason to believe that white
has something else going on for him that
f6 King f7 actually keeps mine I wanted
to avoid the B takes c6 scenario which
is probably not terrible but I didn't
want to have the this pawn structure and
yeah I think this King is actually a
slight acid for black so I'm near the
action and I mean it's equal yeah I'm
not going to tell you that I'm better
here but it's probably roughly equal
yeah Knight is seven stock which gives
me a slight edge which is I mean it is
very very slight but I thought Bishop d7
is a strange move the engine also wants
to go back to e2 as I meant
and why not keep the the bishop on the
board this is still not a fantastically
good piece so I was kind of happy that
that he took it and then yeah we got the
trades going here yeah I wasn't entirely
sure if I should trade roofs don't yeah
I think this is not sure if it leads to
anything after b5 him I I guess I get
this set up and AH a forum that's a good
look probably yeah white wants to trade
stuff he has to find some kind of
defensive setup that holds like pressure
against the pawn
maybe this maybe somewhere here that
gets too slow you went he went back in
kingly - yeah against King it - I wanted
to take go do you form and go up to the
five okay so so here wait but I can
still go a five first right if I go if I
if he gets to play here but he cannot go
to these three because of the knight
move so I get here actually hmm
interesting
okay this is what the engine wants to do
King c4 I'm not threatening the pawn
because the C pawn runs but this is
still an accomplishment to have entered
on c4 hoon
no it still doesn't really do much I
thought I should probably go here but
a4e for us interesting either the
computers I could add shares right good
move takes yeah King King d3 King e6
King c4 very strong he sacrifice a pawn
but the King gets activated and yeah I'm
not sure at all that hmm the engine
gives equal him g4g five of the
counterintuitive move this is doing
actually it's bishop at for a threat or
something if I do they had the problem
is a little bit I'm not sure what I'm
doing next year I mean a move like this
okay I can always jettison the pawn
probably for draw mmm there was a little
bit concerned so this is probably what
you should do I mean here he's giving me
Tempe up he's giving me terribly with a
five and a four and he it probably gets
to the point where you cannot save it
interesting that the engine goes King
defied I was thinking before would win
the pond clean because I thought he can
only protect it with Bishop d6 that is
really weird so what is the engine
smooth Bishop age six aha so it's it i
okay wants to protect it like this and
why is Knight a5 Lord winning stuff I
don't get it this and then he gets
seasick so what I see six is just a draw
Wow
mmm he's picking up everything so this
was a way for him to draw this okay so
the engine wants to play King d5 and but
I have a hard time to believe that I can
win this position I mean I can never
take here is the problem because of the
C pawn and how am I actually entering
here or it's probably a drawn yeah as I
think in practical terms my move was
stronger because he would have to find
Bishop h6 which he didn't and I think
now it's probably gone
we should page six King bee five bishop
f8 hmm it still feels I think it feels
to me that there could be something
might be eight that's interesting let be
a to d7
Jim I have very much sure this this and
then h5 I mean it's not a bad idea
probably to put more stuff on light
squares him what's the f5 comes into
consideration but 66 is amazing the
engine just gives this as a flat-out
draw and yeah maybe this King c-23 yeah
so here here we just trade everything so
he had still very good drawing chance to
see him if he plays it plays it
correctly but he gave me the pawn and it
here is probably a winner I mean I I
scrambled around a little bit but it is
probably a win very simple so yeah
recently my score isn't all that bad
against if it's still bad of course but
I'm on what is that
then I was 7-14 but there were times
where when I never won I mean like never
and I think in recent games I'm close to
50% okay guys thanks for watching